[Music]
I'm pleased to welcome to the platform
George J Mitchell former United States
Senator for Maine and the Honorable
Michael a Sullivan mayor of the city of
Cambridge senator Mitchell will now give
the address to the graduates their
families and friends it's an honor for
me to be part of this important day in
your lives I know that many of you
already are worrying about how long I'm
going to speak so I begin by reassuring
you that my intention is to stop
speaking before you graduates stop
listening I've been asked to discuss my
work in conflict resolution in Northern
Ireland and the Middle East
mindful of the commitment I've just made
my comments will have to be brief I
spent five years working for peace in
Northern Ireland for almost all of that
time there was no progress there was
political posturing delay doubt and many
people died after each death
I spent a sleepless night trying to
fight off a growing feeling of despair
and failure but after years of effort a
peace agreement was finally reached from
that experience I formed the conviction
that there is no such thing as a
conflict that can't be ended conflicts
are created conducted and sustained by
human beings they can be ended
by human beings after completing my work
in Northern Ireland I was asked to go to
the Middle East there the committee
which I chaired made recommendations
which have been incorporated into the
roadmap recently advanced by the United
States the United Nations the European
Union and Russia as we all know last
week it was accepted by Israel and the
Palestinian Authority although only a
first step that acceptance was
significant and it reinforces my
conviction that like all others the
conflict in the Middle East can be ended
among the steps we recommended and which
are included in the roadmap are by the
Palestinian Authority the renunciation
of violence an end to hatred and
incitement and a 100% effort to crack
down on terrorism an effort which has
not yet been made by the government of
Israel the withdrawal of its military
forces to their pre Intifada positions
and the freezing of all settlement
construction activity then there must be
a prompt resumption of negotiations to
achieve a two-state solution what is
most important is that both recognize
that the only way to achieve a lasting
solution is through negotiation if they
are to succeed illusions must be
abandoned on both sides some
Palestinians and other Arabs continue to
believe that they can destroy Israel and
rid the Middle East of a Jewish state
that cannot and will not happen it is a
fantasy that will only generate more
misery and suffering on both sides some
Israelis believe and advocate that all
of the Palestinians
every man woman and child can be
physically uprooted and moved to another
country that cannot and will not happen
it too is a fantasy contributing to the
difficulty of finding a peaceful
resolution is the fact that the
circumstances and objectives of the two
sides are different the Israelis have a
stake what they want is security that is
their overriding objective the
Palestinians don't have a state and they
want one an independent economically
viable geographically contiguous state
that is their overriding objective I
believe that neither can attain its
objective by denying to the other side
its objective Palestinians will never
achieve a state if Israel does not have
security Israel will never get
sustainable security if the Palestinians
don't have a state there are some in
both societies perhaps some here today
who disagree with this assertion but for
me it has been validated by the tragic
events of the past two and a half years
our committees report was very tough on
terrorism we branded it morally
reprehensible and unacceptable
it is also politically counterproductive
it will not achieve its objective to the
contrary with each suicide bomb attack
the prospect of a Palestinian state is
delayed such tactics also are
destructive of Palestinian civil society
and the reputation of the Palestinian
people throughout the world the road map
offers Palestinians the alternative of a
non-violent path to a Jewish state to a
Palestinian state living in peace
alongside a Jewish state the two-state
solution that a majority on both sides
continue to say they support
Palestinians in turn must accept that
the Israeli demand for security is as
real and as necessary as is their demand
for a state both are more likely to
occur if reciprocal steps are taken to
create a context in which meaningful
negotiation can be conducted this can't
be done by the two sides themselves
their mutual mistrust is totally the
culture of peace so carefully nurtured
over the previous decade has been
shattered in its place there has
developed a sense of futility and
despair of the inevitability of conflict
and yet public opinion polls on both
sides show consistent and strong
majorities in support of a two-state
solution and of the political process
needed to bring it about but because of
the impact of the prolonged violence a
majority of Palestinians support suicide
bombings of Israelis and a majority of
Israelis support the use of whatever
force is deemed necessary to suppress
such attacks in other words majorities
on both sides largely agree on the
solution but they no longer trust the
other side's intentions to reach it
they're caught in a zero-sum contest in
which both are suffering time does not
permit me to repeat the long list of our
committees recommendations or the
details of the roadmap most attention
has been given to the cessation of
violence and incitement by Palestinians
and a freeze on all settlement
construction activity by Israelis I have
already commented on and condemned the
failure of terror to advance the
Palestinian cause as to settlements our
committee adopted what has been the
policy of every American administration
for more than a quarter of a century
during the more than 50 year
of its existence Israel has had the
strong support of the United States in
international forums the US has at times
cast the only vote in Israel's behalf
yet even in such a close relationship
there are some differences prominent
among them is the United States
government's long-standing opposition to
the government of Israel's policies and
practices regarding settlements that
u.s. opposition has been consistent
through the Carter Reagan Bush Clinton
and Bush administration's just as
consistent has been the continued
settlement activity by the Israeli
government in his major policy speech on
the Middle East last year President Bush
was explicit he said and I quote Israeli
settlement activity in the occupied
territories must stop consistent with
the recommendations of the Mitchell
Committee the roadmap also refers
specifically to our recommendations on
settlements as we read in this morning's
newspaper there already are serious
problems in implementation of the
roadmaps recommendations there will be
more so I don't underestimate the
difficulties but I believe that an end
to this conflict is possible it is
especially important that we Americans
not turn away when the inevitable
setbacks occur that we not resign
ourselves to the inevitability of
conflict American commitment and
determination are essential the
preservation of a sovereign and secure
Israel and of the peaceful and just
resolution of the conflict in the Middle
East there as elsewhere there is a
universal human desire to lead lives
that are full free and meaningful
because of the wisdom and foresight of
our founding fathers we're fortunate to
live in a society which despite its
imperfections
is the most free the most just the most
open society in all of human history
from that society each of us receives
many benefits with benefits come
responsibilities you've had the good
fortune to receive an advanced education
so you have an important role to play in
preserving and improving our way of life
there's much for all of us to do each of
you students graduates undergraduates
every person present today will have
your own list of our society's domestic
challenges I will mention just a few
that are important to me if you believe
as I do that every American child is
entitled to a good education regardless
of background or family wealth you must
oppose any actions which have the effect
of denying them that opportunity if you
believe as I do that we have an
obligation to leave for future
generations
the very basics of healthy human life
clean air pure water unwise and land you
must demand public policies to honor
that obligation if you believe as I do
that every American is entitled to equal
opportunity and equal justice you must
speak out against all forms of
discrimination and injustice never
forget that in the presence of evil
silence makes you an accomplice the
education you've received at this great
institution is important even necessary
but it is not a guarantee of self-worth
it is not a substitute for a life of
effort how you do it is important just
as important as what you do if you take
pride in what you do you will excel
if you do not take pride in what you do
you cannot excel John Gardner put it
best when he wrote an excellent plumber
is infinitely more admirable than an
incompetent philosopher the society
which scorns excellence in plumbing
because it regards that as a humble
activity and tolerates Schad eNOS and
philosophy because it is an exalted
activity will have neither good plumbing
no good philosophy neither its pipes nor
its theories will hold water for those
undergraduates going on to further
education I have some advice on what not
to do I serve as the Chancellor of the
Queen's University of Northern Ireland
last December our students took a
graduate school entrance exam one of
them frustrated by the difficulty of the
questions wrote an answer to the last
question God alone knows the answer to
this question Merry Christmas
two weeks later he got his paper back
with this note God gets an A you fail
happy new year you are part of a highly
privileged elite in the education you've
received in the opportunities that will
be available to you it is inevitable and
appropriate that you devote much of your
life to earning the income you need to
support yourself and your family like
all human beings you will want status
and wealth and most of you will get them
but the more successful you are the more
evident it will become to you that
there's more to life you will find that
fulfillment in your life will not come
from the expensive things you acquire
not from leisure
not from self-indulgence real
fulfillment and life will come from
striving with all of your physical and
spiritual might for a worthwhile
objective that helps others it is larger
than your self-interest most of all for
you graduates I hope that each of you is
fortunate enough to find such an
objective in your life congratulations
good luck may God bless each one of you
[Applause]